the written house trial continues to
undergo deliberation it is insane to me
that we are still deliberating about
this case i say we i mean the jury this
case is the most clear-cut case of
self-defense i've ever seen in my life
but
they're the the judge yesterday
correctly blasted the media for their
misinformation about the trial here's
what the judge had to say
some of the other misinformation about
the case that is widespread
and you gentlemen are as aware of it as
i am
um
now they had some people
in the milwaukee journal i think i read
it said it was
odd i think was the word that
i didn't gruel on the motion to dismiss
i haven't even had a chance to read the
motion to dismiss i just got it
yesterday
and i really think before i rule on a
motion
i should let the state respond
so why anyone would think that it's odd
for the judge to sit on a motion to
dismiss i have no idea
okay so the media coverage in the case
has been absolutely bizarre he is
exactly right about that and politically
driven well yesterday the prosecution
ran directly into a buzz saw because it
turns out that the prosecution handed
over a badly pixelated version of the
drone footage remember there was drone
footage of the of the first shooting of
joseph rosenbaum by kyle rittenhouse
and it turns out that the prosecution
had that for a long time and finally
when they turned it over it was a badly
pixelated version of the video according
to breitbart the dispute involved
several videos especially a high
definition video the prosecution used in
closing arguments on friday which had
not been provided to the defense which
received only a low res version the
defense moved for a mistrial tuesday on
that basis
ada john krause told the judge the
prosecution had not intentionally
withheld video evidence from the defense
but there was an accidental compression
involved in moving video between iphone
and android devices
the person who took the footage
according to crouse had earlier provided
it to rittenhouse's former attorney john
pierce who had shown it last year on the
tucker carlson show on fox news when it
was emailed to the defense there was a
compression he said which had not been
deliberate
he said um he had no idea how to
compress the files the defense counter
the files appeared to be different and
the metadata accompanying the video
appeared it different
the defense also said the video provided
to tucker carlson was different as it
was black and white the prosecutor's
video was in color that had not been the
problem but rather the superior quality
of the prosecution's video
defense lawyer mark richard said at this
point your honor they've not requested
what we're fighting about you're correct
the judge replied
earlier on wednesday the jury did send a
question to the judge about whether it
would be permitted to review video
evidence in the courtroom or in private
so that came in late yesterday afternoon
okay so
the prosecutors
tried to claim that it was just a
technical glitch the defense said that
this video evidence was compressed by
the prosecution and passed over to them
in order to deceive them which wouldn't
be a shock because there have been
serious evidentiary questions throughout
here is a the defense making that
argument
the one that was provided to the state's
crime lab that attorney finger gave me a
copy of on saturday had a very long
convoluted title that involves lots of
letters and numbers that are
the type that are usually associated
with files taken from a drone because
they indicate
a lot of different information like the
location of the drone and the time the
file i received originally on friday the
fifth
was
not labeled that same and was not the
same file amount
there's no way that what ada krause is
saying is true because
the file name would not have changed if
my computer was compressing anything it
was a different file that we were
provided from what was provided to the
state at least for what attorney binger
gave me on saturday they're completely
different
okay meanwhile the prosecution admitted
there was a technical glitch but they
said it was just a technical glitch no
biggie the defense by the way is arguing
that one of the reasons the prosecution
did this is because they were looking
for a mistrial because this is going so
badly for them
i think we're focusing on
too heavily on
i guess a technological glitch
and less on the and we should be
focusing that
this exhibit was played the jury is
asking to see in exhibits that they have
seen
they didn't know about this video they
tried to find it just as we did
we found it and there was a
technological glitch
or not a glitch but i guess a
it worked in a way that is designed that
we were not aware of and i do not
believe
a
technical reality shall we say or a
technical
an unknown
technical incident
should result in a mistrial
yeah um
yeah sure okay meanwhile the media
continue their habit of drawing the most
bizarre narratives out of this case
farhad manju who somehow has finagled a
column at the new york times which is
amazing because truly is there is a
running battle between the members of
the new york times editorial board about
which one of them is the worst columnist
farhad manju is definitely near the top
of the list i think it goes like charles
blow paul krugman farhad managing but
he's climbing the list each and every
day uh he had a piece yesterday in which
he argued that the the big problem in
the kyle rittenhouse case was the gun
not the people rioting in the streets
attacking the guy with the gun the gun
according to firehead manju the lead
prosecutor thomas binger offered a
meticulously documented closing argument
that definitely summarized all the ways
written house acted unlawfully we'll see
if the jury buys it but to me binger's
argument had a power beyond this case
that's because it cleverly unraveled
some of the foundational tenets of gun
advocacy that guns are effective and
necessary weapons of self-defense well
i'm not sure how that was unraveled
considering that
rittenhouse would probably be dead today
or at the very least in a coma in a
hospital if um if he had not had a gun
he says that without them lawlessness
and tyranny would prevail lawlessness
and tyranny did prevail in kenosha
wisconsin
and that in the right hands in the hands
of the good guys guns promote public
safety rather than destroying it
well i mean they do there just weren't
enough guns there in the hands of the
good guys there's one good guy with gun
kyle rittenhouse in this particular case
up against an entire riotous mob
one of whom was a child molester trying
to attack him another of whom was a
convicted criminal was trying to attack
him with a skateboard and a third of
whom was approaching him with his own
gun but says firehead manju in the
written house case none of that was true
at every turn that night ridden house's
ar-15 style semi-automatic rifle made
things worse ratcheting up danger rather
than quelling it the gun transformed
situations that might have ended in
black eyes and broken bones into ones
that ended with corpses in the street
well whose fault is that the people
attacking the guy with the gun or the
guy with the gun
but you know the left must have its
narratives so we'll continue to keep an
eye on the jury in that particular case
honestly i'm shocked they still have not
come back in at this point
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feed